I can't believe I'm actually doing this
Quinn maybe this was about it bro what
are you doing no don't don't like look
at me turn around protect pretend I'm
not here you don't know me you said you
were here for moral support
no bro I'm here to eavesdrop in live
tweet the [ __ ] out of your pathetic
Valentines yes not pathetic Rachel and I
have something really special Rachel yes
from the internet yes the unbelievably
hot but approachable Warby Parker comm
homepage model looking babe but you've
been cyber blasting for three months
don't want to rush things that was our
promise on the gut Garrett turn around
and stop talking to me are you get it
yeah oh my gosh are you waiting for
Rachel yeah yeah so she's running late
so she sent me instead I'm her roommate
Mitchell
nature nice to meet you it's not so
great to finally meet you can like so
much hotter than your profile photo it's
like my lady boners like going Wow right
huh thanks I guess I know so much about
you and mean Rachel's luck she's told me
so much about you like loads it's like
Rachel never mentioned she had a
roommate look at me I'm just blabbing on
over here just bluh bluh bluh bluh bluh
bluh bluh like Oh Mike I'm gonna go get
some croissants cuz they like the best
here so I'm gonna be right back okay
this is great go you do realize what's
happening right now right yeah Rachel's
running a bit late so Nietzsche came to
let me know oh my god nacho Gare I can't
believe you don't see this Rachel's not
real one day was no Rachel wouldn't know
she only has one profile photo messages
you like 20 times a day and has never
ever wanted to meet in person we're
taking things slow oh my god it's kind
of like you but is shipping you in the
kidney and you're just like bleeding out
all over the floor and I'm like oh okay
oh no text right just being in terrible
quarantine oh my oh my god a car
accident is she okay a car it's like
totally destroyed so now she's can be
like I don't know like really really
oh my god I'm doing this okay cause like
now you and I we'd have like more time
to talk and it's really brave that
you're taking this step I think you're
still working through your emotions and
not getting over shells so that's how do
you know about shell that was a private
thing that I told Rachel oh no don't
worry it's like Rachel and me were like
she shares everything with me well I
basically like the same person are you
wearing the sleater-kinney t-shirt I
sent Rachel for her birthday
hilarious like I'm always excellently
wearing a clothes like it's like silly
because I'm not literally Rachel right
now like oh my gosh I like totally
forgot to get us a coffee so like I'll
be right back bro this is totally like
that scene in Inception I'm getting to
watch a train wreck unfold in slow
motion outside of the could you treat a
person like this the whole time it was
you Rachel are you okay what happened I
didn't I thought you were the one
Garrett stupid Rachel wait Rachel wait I
love you never contact me again
Oh bro now I like really want to watch
inception
sup guys happy Valentine's Day on like a
less sexy note my roommate Garrett is
gone missing he's a lobster five six red
shell probably crying if you have like
any information on his whereabouts
please post in the comments below
Garrett if you're watching come home III
need your copy of Inception